this is no time for you to resign I'm
not resigning just taking a leave of
absence besides if you need help Barbara
is more than ready to step up agreed but
dick I need a break Kathir you me Wally
me we founded this team without him I
understand this team has had successes
but much remains to be done
Superboy Miss Martian Beast Boy your
alpha the ours of whom has called from
Mars he needs help
tigress Kid Flash bumblebee Guardian
your beta Lex Corp is bringing out the
reach soft drink under a new name we
need proof business as usual
[Music]
I'm sorry Otto
we couldn't find a transplant then your
sister honor the heart just gave out
initiating
[Music]
[Applause]
kind of big I just sat bug me here in
the dream landfall
[Music]
just happy I don't hear a heartbeat no
no no that wasn't enough juice to kill
anything
she it is a she or was scans indicate
heart failure and I'm reading a female
approximate age 14 earth years yes I'm
sorry but this is a human girl a child
the heroes you demanded that's the
commitment we were looking for are
finally back I never wear super suit
sorry pal this counts young justice
outsiders Punk DC Universe
now you just have to hit me new faces
new episodes new adventures get super
well got to cover Young Justice
Outsiders premiering January 4th only on
DC Universe join now hey everybody it's
Charlie Happy New Year we have the
opening scene from a Young Justice
Season three Episode one so I'll break
that down and just remind people about
what the schedule for the show is going
to be because it's all coming back
January 4th this Friday we have some
sick looking new art of Aqualad who has
since become the new version of Aquaman
the reasons why aren't immediately
answered so we won't find out about that
till later this season but it's just a
really badass upgrade for his costume
there's a new giveaway for the DC
streaming service membership all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Young Justice
moment on the video but you start out in
the clip with a little bit of extra
footage from the end of season 2 so this
is like new stuff that's cut into the
end of season two with Nightwing saying
that he's leaving the team for a little
while you find out why later he reminds
Aqualad that Batgirl is stepping up in a
really big way that's important for
later so remember that like a lot of
this is foreshadowing in setting things
up that they pay off later during
episode one but then it's business as
usual as Aqualad divides everybody up
into different teams to address the
ongoing threats with the light and other
things on planet earth and
intergalactically like it's a really big
team a really big roster of characters
and there's all a lot of ongoing threats
that they have to handle in different
places that seem like they're
disconnected but then with all things
like you did during Young Justice season
1 in season 2 you find out that
everything is connected because of some
larger play by Vandal Savage in the
light so if it wasn't clear the light is
still the big villain of Young Justice
season 3 but what they don't show you in
this clip is that other scene that we
got at the end of season 2 with Darkseid
and Vandal Savage meeting saying like oh
right we're gonna start this great new
partnership and you see apocalypse you
know where Darkseid lives in the opening
credits of every single Young Justice
season 3 episode so we're just a way for
them to subtly remind you what's going
on in the background even though this
first big clip here just sort of teased
up the mystery of season 3 or at least
the first half of season 3 this
metahuman traffic
and it's largely centered on markovia
which is where like that picks up after
the two-year time jump so I'll address
that in a second because there is a time
jump in what's going on in outer space
that you see in the later clip with the
Justice League characters so first big
thing the time jump you see here is two
years so it's 2016 during these events
here at least for the first couple of
episodes as far as I know but remember
it's Young Justice so they still do the
dates so that helps you place everything
in the timeline so when they flash those
little date cards throughout the
episodes those are really important so
be sure to pay attention to those
because they're just happy to keep track
of where all the characters are and when
this is all happening but two years go
by you find yourself in a Children's
Hospital in markovia
this is dr. X he's the lead scientists
in the lights efforts to weaponize
metahumans on planet Earth as you can
see the clip play out he's using the
hospital as a front to create metahumans
because it's a hospital they need urgent
care or they need some medicine for
something while they're there he tests
them for the meta-gene if they test
positive he wheels them into their
version of the Weapon X program remember
the first deadpool movie when deadpool
went to the Weapon X program and they
tested him with a bunch of different
things to try and activate his X gene
well this is DC so it's not the X gene
it's the meta-gene but it's the exact
same thing this black goo is what they
used to try and activate their powers so
if they're successful then you see what
happens to them later because a couple
weeks later you see plasmus on the back
of this darkside apocalyptan ship
jumping into a war on ran so we'll talk
about that in a second but the other
thing that you have to remember here too
because when they wheeled the girl off
and that really sinister person is like
be quiet dr. X comes back to her brother
and says aw we're really sorry she
didn't survive she is dead so he's
really sad and it's implied that you
know she tested positive because she
shows up on ran as plasmus but you don't
find out what happens to the brother
till much later they're twins
if she had the meta-gene he probably had
it too so that'll come back around but
you have this newly created weapon of
mass destruction showing up on the back
of a troop ship with a bunch of
parademons jumping off to start a ward
looking like they're trying to conquer
the planet ran which is a big easter egg
for the Adam Strange comics so if you
notice the New Gods looking technology
on the back
as a chip that's a control chip to make
sure that their new weapon quote-unquote
is compliant so because it's all this
mother box tech these are parademons
it's implied that this is probably
Darkseid who's buying or paying for all
these new metahuman weapons that are
being created with Earthlings but the
newly created plasmas jumps off into
battle you see Adam strange a bunch of
other Justice League characters this is
his wife I believe a lot of strange you
see ice you see Wonder Woman but the
major WTF moment here is black lightning
accidentally killing plasma snot
realizing what's going out like just
using his regular lightning powers
accidentally stopping her heart then
them learning about the mystery that
it's an Earthling that's only 14 years
old just a normal girl how did she wind
up here on ran in this giant war that's
just the mystery that they're going to
solve during the course of season 3 or
the first half of season 3 that'll tee
them up as they try to disrupt metahuman
trafficking find out who's behind it and
then uncover a larger mystery with
what's going on with Vandal Savage in
Darkseid so it's just the tipping point
like episode 1 is really just letting
you know where all the characters are
what's happened in the last two years
how everyone's relationships have
changed a lot of stuff has changed I'm
under embargo so I can't post my review
of the entire season until I think
Wednesday so that'll be a non-spoilery
video no worries because only the first
three episodes are dropping on Friday
and there's gonna be about 13 episodes
in the first half of this season but
because a lot of the plot of season 3
turns on stuff that's happening in
markovia geo force Breann Markov is a
really big new character they introduced
so a lot of the plot turns on what he
does in the first couple of episodes I
assume it's gonna be the same for the
rest of the season but there's a lot of
other stuffs we can talk about there's a
crazy number of characters so far is
looking great so be sure to check it out
this Friday when it all drops what'll
happen is is even though it's the
holiday week I'll be doing videos like
normal leave your requests in the
comments below another a lot of
questions about reverse flash flash
season 5 stuff so maybe I'll do a video
about that in the next day or two while
you wait for everything click here for
my Titans season 2 teaser trailer video
and click here for my brand-new Captain
Marvel trailer video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]